welcome to this video playing pixie who
finland in finland and try modern
defense here was g66 yeah asics this was
analyzed and then they're in a really
good entertaining and interesting
opening book court Tigers modern by
Tiger Hill a pass on the Swedish player
he's really named tiger like Tiger Woods
um and I made this um he brought this
really excellent book on the model and
they were at it almost made me play this
opening but okay I can't do I can play
them in blitz but I never dared to to go
for it in tournament chess always seem
to Ted risky to me okay but um nette
fact in in them I think next year he
will release um revised or a new a new
book sort of revised version of this
book and the first one was called Tigers
modern and the new one we called the
modern tiger no joke I think it's really
cold that way ok so right set up a big
center that tried to undermine it with
the c5 the bishop is looking at this
efore pole and now h5 intends to play h
for winning the e4 pawn so putting
utmost pressure on the center what I'm
wondering is can you play would be one
or something taking the the bishop yeah
okay
I don't really know it was somewhat
annoying him he has problems defending
the center yeah this is of course a
possibility but I thought 95 would be
good attacking III and attacking c3 only
question is should I play or should I
play just taking on d4 195 this is
actually a good move Bishop b4 is what
would irritate me slightly but okay okay
okay if he goes Bishop before now I can
even think about f5 which looks in
hmm yeah maybe maybe a five you takes no
g6 is hanging of course yeah this was
another another possibility I thought
night f8 would be okay but maybe I'm
mistaken I have a good good prospects in
terms of destroying his Center but yeah
doesn't help you if you're getting meted
my king okay I'll play it this way and
run for 14 cavalcade it's obviously a
very wild position but the thing is I
have played in the center it's not
completely clear maybe I'm amber syeds
it's possible very much because well the
king is obviously important to jest but
maybe it's not so bad yeah all night
here and 96 yeah this is Sam this is
quite quite serious maybe here
yeah I'm giving an exchange if he plays
Knight f7 largest kill King d7 night h8
Bishop AJ then I've got a temper on g6
hmm and must do something something
drastic in the center hmm gap probably
this is all nonsense and lost for black
but it's soulless an affair Lee
complicated one thing is this is
actually interesting if he goes Knight
f7 king d 7 9 h8 I can take III Queen
III and seat XD for this is in fact
interesting and this is some counter
player maybe this is even even playable
yeah he's taking his sweet time it's not
easy 9320 3cd father's assam was
actually dangerous so he retreats hmm
okay
if I go if I take him
night III should be seven would be and
now it's this is a bit lame take care
who cannot really take on c3
andrew p8 is really really two to meet
okay I just spotted that I can play
Knights you for I saw that really late
but this is some this is interesting
of course this is some super complicated
i probably I probably I'm just I'm just
lost here but yeah it's not it's not
totally easy here
so uh if it takes the night isn't a pin
down I'll get you three give what the
wacky game
yeah probably just losing for black but
not easy and how I get a phone call
great middle of this nonsense game I
come on I call back so what's no Jeff
come on okay i hope i didn't blunder
everything here I can't simply cannot
play with this damn phone ringing it's a
really an amazingly bad school after
after I need the phone ringing okay it
also let's see what happens here I can
play Knight f7 still and he doesn't do
it I just covered a 6cm which was
probably probably not the best move okay
it's just placed for an attack which is
so I'm not such a bad idea prolly okay i
knowi Fife is not good man what the heck
okay let's just hope he won't make it
time-wise check the position is not
exactly easy to play okay he's got a
check here but it's it's just a check
check
check
time more check
check rookie one at the end white
forfeits on time so it's even a winning
position but ok this was just a
completely chaotic chaotic game where I
was probably just lost yeah probably no
not probably I was just lost him I think
I'm here it's a it's a fairly normal
position for this for this opening even
here I'm pretty optimistic that this
should be okay and here here this is
this is something that I missed I should
just take III him I have switched on the
comb to give me some hints the compounds
to take here check because this is
actually very good yeah Bishop f3 sm is
funny the point is if it if he captures
there's this move and after that you you
win you win lots of material and also I
already have a couple of pawns yeah I
didn't didn't see that at all and after
here check it's just an awful mess m93
computer actually says is about equal
mmhmm yeah here it goes oh here could
take be several I didn't consider that
with the perpetual okay funny enough the
computer gives us a sequel for the
moment yeah but ok it's only i'm running
a fun couple of seconds so i just it's
just an awful mess and the round here
we busted I think instead of f5 you can
you can just take it also night f7 and
take it I remember look down how to
believe that it should be winning okay
this is just just as much an awful mess
check yeah useless to analyze this kind
of stuff it's just a complete mess with
no time on the clock but yeah the model
is interesting fighting opening it's not
for people with the we're with a week
yeah with weak nerves because whites got
this big center and always sort of
threatens to break through but you have
some counterplay going against it okay
thanks for watching